welcome to this comprehensive video
course on JavaScript testing with just a
powerful and widely used testing
framework this course covers just
features and capabilities and will teach
you how to write run and organize tests
efficiently to enhance your JavaScript
projects popular teacher Tommy too
created this course hi there and welcome
to this course I am Tommy from free code
camp in this course you will learn how
to use just to test your JavaScript code
just is a power testing framework for
JavaScript and in this tutorial we will
cover everything from the basic concept
to mocking and also in synchronous
testing by the end of this course you
will have the skills to implement just
into your project confidently now let's
get straight into this course so now the
first thing that we're going to do is to
create a folder where we're going to be
doing all our work so right now I'm just
in the root directory of my computer I'm
going to go into
document and in there I'm going to go
into my project
folder and I'm going to create a new
actually I'm just going to create a new
directory named so I'm just going to say
mkd i r just
course and I'm going to go into just
course now if I press LS to see
everything in this folder you're going
to see that it's blank so what we're
just doing is kind of like creating a
playground where we can experiment and
see just in action so this is just the
folder right here and as you can see I
named the just C name it whatever you
want to name it and yeah so now the next
thing that we're going to do is to just
like initialize a new mpm project so
what I'm going to do is that in here I'm
going to say
mpm in it so this is the normal command
you use to just initialize a new project
but I'm going to add i y now the reason
why I add i y is like a shortcut to
answer yes to all the prompt so once I
run mpm in it if there's any prompt
that's going to come up once once I put
i y right here it's just going to bypass
all of that and answer yes so just so we
can have like a default setup and also
like a quick setup I'm going to hit
enter and now that is done if I press LS
again you can now see that we have a
package.json file right here so what I'm
now going to do is to open up this just
C folder inside my vs code I'm going to
swipe to vs code right here and what I'm
just going to do is to save file open
folder and then I'm just going to look
for my vs code right here so right here
in just going to try to find my project
test course I'm going to open this up so
right here as you can see so right here
as you can see we have opened up just
course and this is the package. Json
that we have right here just a
normal mpm project now what we're just
going to do the next thing that we're
going to do after doing that is to now
actually install just into this
particular you know this particular
project so for us to install just um the
next what we're going to do is to run
mpm
install two I say
save dev then just so the reason why we
choosing just again is just for it
Simplicity and it's Rich pictures so
just is like I think the most popular
know frame or library that we can use to
run JavaScript tests and that's why
we're using just for this course so this
is the command that you're going to use
to actually install just into this
project that we just created and now
what I'm just going to do is to click on
enter and that is going to start
installing just into this project now as
I said it's going to install just
locally into this project and it's going
to add it to the dep dependency in our
package.json if I come here there's once
it's done you're going to see something
named Dev dependency and that just means
that it is this particular library that
we're installing is essential for the
development of this our projects but is
not essential for running the actual
application so you don't really need to
know all of those details what you just
need to know is that what we are running
right now is to install j into this
project and now once that installs
you're going to see a new folder here is
going to be created named node modules
as you can see that was created but
let's wait for it to properly install
now as you can see everything was
installed successfully it added just so
it says added 292 packages and found Z
zero vulnerabilities which is what we
want now if I come back in here let's
verify that this installation actually
worked so now we have a package look.
Json and then we have the actual
package.json so first if we come in here
you can see that we have a node module
folder this means that we actually
installed a particular library or a
module and in this package. Json once I
come in here the dep dependencies I was
talking about initially
this is it right here so once this has
been added under here you can see that
we have just added to De dependencies
now this just confirms that just has
been added successfully as you can see
so now that just has been added
successfully the next thing is to
actually configure our npm script to run
just when we want to execute tests so
what we're going to do is to just open
up package of Json and change some stuff
so npm scripts are convenient shortcut
we can set up to run specific commands
so we're going to set one up now for J
now I'm going to open up package.json
and right here this is package of Json
is like our project manifest so let's
just modify it to run test using just
now on here what we're going to do is
where we see I just come here where we
see test so under script under the
script section so this default tests
we're going to change it to just going
to say just
right and then what this does this means
that whenever we run the command mpm
test it's going to use just to execute
that test now this is what we want to do
we're just going to save this this is
what we need to do and then now with our
setup ready we can dive into just and
dive more into how we can actually run
tests using this G now let's go into the
basic concepts of testing with just so
now that we have set up just and we have
everything done the next thing that we
want to do is to write our first test so
this is going to introduce us to the
fundamental concepts in just now what
we're going to do is that we're going to
write a very simple unit test and before
we move forward let me explain what unit
test is so unit test is the process of
checking small pieces of code to deliver
information early and often so when we
are testing when we are doing or running
a unit test it means that we testing
small blocks of code so things like
basic functions or basic classes that is
unit testing now the reason why we do
this is so that we can easily identify
errors or any box that's going to come
up right from the scratch so that
instead of testing the whole code when
it's done and that is going to be harder
because once we get an error it's going
to be harder to actually find where the
error is coming from but unit test
allows us to
easily get or capture this error early
on while we're still you know doing our
basic functions and basic coding blocks
now we're going to run a basic unit test
using just and let me show you how to do
that now the first thing we need to do
is I'm just going to close this and
right here I'm going to create a new
file named sum.
JS now this sum. JS is actually a
Javascript file where we're going to be
writing a function that is just going to
add two F add two numbers together and
return the addition or the sum of those
numbers and I'm going to create another
file named sum. test.js now this is a
test file so once we write the actual
function in here we're going to kind of
like export that particular function and
we're going to retrieve that function in
this test file and then we're going to
actually run the unit test so now what
we're going to do is to come back in
here and right here in sjs I'm just
going to write a basic JavaScript
function so I'm going to say function
I'm going to name it sum
just increase this a little bit and I'm
going to say it's going to take two
inputs A and
B and we're just going to open and close
that function and that function is going
to return the sum of those two numbers
so it's going to return a plus b now the
next thing we're going to do is to
actually export this particular function
so that it can be used by other files in
this particular directory so what I'm
going to do is to say
module. export
equals to sum and I'm going to add my
semicolon very important now that I have
all of this done the next thing I can
just do is to actually run a test so the
first thing I just did is just creating
this basic sum function taking two
inputs and it's going to add those
inputs and return
the value or the sum of those inputs now
I'm going to make as I said using this
mod export equals sum it makes this sum
function available to other files like
this test file in nodejs right here so
now I'm going to access this particular
function in this sum. test.js and I'm
going to run a unit test right there but
now what I'm going to do is to just
explain how this works so as I said
we're using just and when we say sum do
test.js once we add test before adding
Js JavaScript automatically knows that
we're trying to run a test so it knows
that this is a file dedicated to running
tests now what we're now going to do is
to say const sum so what I'm doing is
I'm using require to import this sum
function into this test file so I'm
going to say equals to
require and I'm going to say dot SL sum
now this Imports it into this particular
folder file and now I can actually run
the test so I'm going to say
test not this say
test and now this is going to be a
description so this comes in two so it
it has like a pair so once we run test
and we have a bracket I'm going to have
right here I'm going to write the
description so I'm just going to say
description and right here after the
description I'm going to have like a
test function I'm just going to leave it
like this and we're going to come right
here to now add an actual description so
what is the description of this function
so what are this test that we're going
to run so we're going to say it adds 1 +
2 to equal
three so what we're going to do is that
we're going to run a test by giving so
I'm going to come back in here so we're
going to give it this values of one and
two and when we add one and two
theoretically this function should
return three because it's just adding
one and two and it's giving us three and
that's what we're going to say in here
so the description is saying it adds one
and two and it should equal three and
then after having the description now
we're going to have the actual function
so to have the actual text function so
we're going to come here and do this
like this and equals
to the greater than sign then we're
going to open the function and then
we're going to say expect
so
expect some now we're going to use that
function one and going to give it two
one and two and we're going to say 2 B
so this is like another pair and it's
just saying once we run this one and two
function the answer should be or the
response should be three and then we're
going to have our semicolon to close
this and we also need to come here and
close this now this is all we need and
let me just quickly explain this
particular code once again so now what
we just doing is we are importing this
sum function from here so we can run
test of about that function and then we
are basically introducing this test
right here which is a like a a global
case for defining a test case right here
in this test function and this structure
which is the description and then we
have the actual function right here and
the last thing is that we did is to
input the pairs so we have the expect
and 2 BP so as I said expect means we
expect that once we run this sum
function and give it these values the
response should B three now what we need
to do is to now just run the test so for
us to run the test and get the results
we have to save these two files make
sure they are saved and then we're going
to pop up a terminal right here
and then all we just need to do is to
make sure we're in this folder yes we
are so let's just clear that and now
we're going to say mpm
test so as you can see that test didn't
go through it says Echo error no test
specified so that means there is a
problem when we set up our package.json
I'm just going to close this up and
close that so right here where we have
script just and we say all of this so as
you can see it's basically giving us
this error message that is what was
given to us right here no test specified
now this is because we replace the test
with just instead of the actual value so
this should be test the the key should
be test not just and then the value
should be
just so we just need to rectify that
error and once that is rectified we can
close this open up that terminal again
and now we can say mpm
test and let's wait for that to run
good as you can see it says one test is
passed one total and as you can see one
passed one total so it run one test in
total and out of that one test one was
passed so basically everything that was
run was passed and snapshot zero total
and this was the time it take to run to
run the test and as you can see this is
the main message we looking for pass
some. test.js it adds 1 + 2 and it
equals 3 so as you can see right here we
have successfully run our first unit
test and this is how we can use J to
easily run a test or unit test right
here in JavaScript so what we just did
was to create a simple function and then
we wrote a test for it and run that test
now I'm going to emphasize how
understanding this foundational concept
is crucial for writing more complex test
so this seems like a very easy and the
most basic test you could write but it's
actually crucial and important that you
understand how to write basic test like
this before you can go ahead and
actually run more complex and advanced
tests so we're going to be talking about
matchers in just and matchers are just
used to test different type of data so
they basically let us assert values in
different ways so right here this is a
matcher this to be right here so when we
have the function or the test function
this is the test desription right here
we have the test function so we have the
expect and then we have the matcher so
these 2B is one type of match there are
various type of matchers there is Tob to
equal to truy to faly to throw I'm going
to talk about every single one of this
right now the first one I'm going to
talk about is to be and that is what we
already I've already shown you in the
initial example that we did now as you
can see right here what this is is just
to be and we saying sum 1 + 2 to be3 so
what we're just going to do is to get
rid of this and I'm just going to start
again and show you how the 2B matcher
actually works so what I want to show
you is to Tob is basically used to for
primitive values so values like numbers
strings and booleans that what Tob is
for and I'm going to show you what I
mean by that so now let's just quickly
write a simple test but we don't need to
import any function from some. JS we
were not really going to be working with
this file for now we just going to be
doing everything from here cuz I'm just
showing you basic examples so
description we're going to say 2 + 2 is
four and then right here we're going to
have to have open and close bracket and
then we're going to have to a function
now we're going to say
expect 2 +
2 to
B four
now what this 2B is going to do if 2 + 2
is four then it's going to tell us the
test has been successfully passed but we
only use this 2B when as I said when we
are dealing with values like numbers
strings and Boolean so this is a number
if it was a string if it was anything
dealing with string or Boolean we're
going to use Tob also now if I open up
my terminal let me just make sure we
save this let's bring back that terminal
just going to say mpm test
again and this is going to run
successfully it says one pass now that
is how we use to be right now the next
thing that we're going to talk about is
to equal so to equal is used when
comparing the values of object or arrays
right so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to create basically a new
dictionary in here so let's just say
test let's create another one and and
let's say something move this and let's
say something like
object
assignment open and close and right here
we're going to create a new dictionary
we're going to say data
equals I we just say
one
I one right and then right now what I'm
just going to do is to say
data two just giving it another value
equals to
two now we expect that the values of
this data dictionary now should be 1 col
1 comma 2 colum 2 because we added a new
key value pair which is two and then two
right so that what we expected but in
this case we're not going to say to be
so I'm going to say
expect
data so we expect this data now that we
created here we're going to say dot to
equal so we expect it to
equal now we can just type in what we
need 1 col 1 and then
2 2 so this is what we expect it to be
going to keep this
spacing add the semicolon now come down
here and add the semicolon so now I'm
not going to say we expect this two be
this because we are not like dealing
with directly dealing with primitive
values like numbers or strings this is
an object basically so because we are
dealing with object or arrays or
anything like that then we have to say
to equal now what we're just going to do
is to come up here and then we're going
to say mpm test again
and because everything should be working
successfully it says one pass one total
now as you can see what this basic
JavaScript code does is we're creating
this new object name data and then we
are now inputting another value in there
as 2 col 2 so now the total value of
everything that should be in data should
be equals to this because it is equals
to that that's why that particular test
was passed
successfully now we've talked about two
be and we've talked about to equal now
the next match we're going to talk about
is the truthy and falsey matchers I'm
just going to demonstrate how to test
for truthy and F falsey values in just
so the first thing we're going to do is
to test for truthy values no we're going
to test for FAL falsy values the first
thing so when we're testing for faly
values so the way we test for faly
values is just the way we say to equal
right here we're going to say to be
FY and this doesn't really work in this
situation but we're going to change that
so I'm just showing you how you're going
to test for it so I'm going to write a
code now that is going to test that
we're going to have to use this to be FY
now we just used faly to check if a
value is n undefined if it's false if
it's zero if it's blank if it's n and or
as I said undefined so that is what we
use falc for and let me show you an
example so let's just start
test go
back and we're just going to say no is
falsy and then like
this
to and now let's say const nals to no so
n is no and then we're going to say
expect
n do to be faly so because n is no we
expect it to be
faly so this should be this test should
be run successfully as I said to be FAL
is is to check if a value is not
undefined ver false zero blank or n n
now because this n is no this test
should be true and it should run
successfully so now let's pop up that
terminal once again and then let's run
mpm test it enter let me expand it you
can see it has been passed successfully
now this just shows that to be FC worked
now on the other hand the next thing
that we can check is TR to be truthful
to be truthy so before we go there I'm
just going to show you one more thing so
as I said this is not just only for when
is no if n is zero or n is false or n is
any of those other values is going to
also be true so let me just say let me
say 0o is faly so I'm going to give this
a value of zero now n is zero so now
we're expecting n to be falsy going to
save it if I run that again mpm test
you're going to see that that run
successfully now as I said next thing
we're going to do is to check to be
truthy so what we're just going to do is
I'm going to show you how we used to be
truthy to check or to test if a value is
like not any of this so basically if a
value is not falsy it is truthy so we
say this is zero but if I say one
because that is not falsy and I say to
be
truy right here and then what I can just
do is to say Z
is
one
trophy now this should run successfully
if I come up here and say mpm test one
should be truthy and we say one passed
now if I change this back to falsey so
you just see that it's not every time
that actually passes if we make a
mistake it's not going to pass now once
I run this you're going to see it says
one failed one total this is because to
be
FY should only be true or should only be
successful when the value of of n is
basically any of those PR any of those
values zero you know false you know
undefined null any of those stuff like
that now the last thing that we're going
to be talking about in matchers is error
handling with to throw so what we use
error handling for is just to determine
whether a function throws an error and
just the way we have to be FY to to
equal and all of that we have to throw
for you know checking error matches
that's what
we for checking errors basically that's
what we use that for now I'm just going
to show you how to use this practically
so for us to basically use this
practically what we're going to do is to
write our own test again and once we
write the test I'm going to show you
that once a particular error is thrown
or an invalid input is thrown then it
should give us that error so the first
thing I'm going to do is to make sure
that you understand the to throw so the
to throw so it's going to say like this
to throw that's what this is and as I
said is used for error handling so it's
arror handling is a very essential
aspect of testing in JavaScript in
general so particularly when you expect
a function to throw an error under
certain conditions and it should throw
that error that's why we want to test to
make sure those errors are being thrown
now as we are using just in here it
provides us this to throw function so we
can use this for this purpose and this
basically helps us write test that
verify whether a function throws an
error when it is called so for the to
throw specifically so this match in just
is used to test that a particular
function throws an error when it is
executed just as I said now this is
particularly useful when you're testing
functions that are designed to validate
input and throw errors when the input is
invalid so let's do that right now so
I'm just going to write a basic syntax
of how to use this to throw and we're
just going to say
test nope and then we're going to say
throws on invalid
input right
here open and close enter now we're
going to say
expect and then what we're just going to
do is after expect we basically want to
have something that throws an error so
right here well we need to
do
say put one up in here so we want to do
this actually we we don't because we
already have so right here in
expect we have open and closed we need
to make sure the syntax is correct so we
open
this
and I have another one in
here
this now we can hit enter and then we
could just say for now let's say my
function inval
input and then dot to
throw right here so in this example my
function is a function that we are
testing an inv valid input is some input
that is expected to basically cause the
function to throw an error so what we
need to do is to write an
actual function for this my function so
what I'm going to do is to say going to
save this we could write that function
in here or we could you know write it
outside and just import it in here so
what I'm just going to do is to write a
function to write another
function and I'm going to name it my
function and it's just going to take an
input so we're just going to say
if input is
invalid we're going to take care of how
to get if the input is invalid so if the
input is invalid what we want to do is
to basically do something in here we're
going to
throw not here right here throw new
error we're just going to say invalid
input
so how do we check if the input is
invalid so we'll say
if type of input is not equals to A
number that means in this case that
input should be invalid if the type of
the input is not equals to number so
what we're just going to do is since
this type of input is not equals to
number then that should be invalid for
us and and we're just going to have to
export this particular function to just
the way we exported the form the sum
function initially just going to export
that and then right here going to come
back to just and we're just going to
say
const my function equals to
require just slash
sum we're going to sa my
function so now we can use my function
in here because we've already imported
it from here so we exported this we
don't really need this we could get rid
of all of this and we could save this
just make sure we're copying this
correctly function and my function so
now we can basically use all of this and
what this does is if the input is
invalid then it's not going to work so
what we're going to do now is that right
here in sjs so this invalid input uh we
don't really have any value we giv it so
I'm just going to give it like a string
and let's save it now let's open this up
and then let's say mpm
test and let's
see and it failed and let's see why it
failed
it said TR mode not found now this is
because right here we're getting the sum
file so this is saying do/ some. JS
basically and then we could give it my
function so now let's run this
again the mistake we made was we changed
some to my function and when we change
some to my function there was no actual
there was no any file here named my
function so it gave us an error but now
we got this my function from right here
from do/ suum so that should work so as
you can see now it passed it says throws
on invalid input now because that input
is invalid it throws that error for us
because we are expecting a number but
now let's say we actually put a number
let's save it and then run npm test
again so now as you can see it said one
failed now why does one fail this is
because this is not actually an invalid
input this is a very valid input because
we the for it to be invalid it needs to
be not a number but this is a number so
it's not going to throw an error that is
why that failed so that is basically a
summary of matchers in just and that is
why why we use matchers and why matchers
is actually very powerful in testing in
JavaScript in general so now we are
going to be testing a synchronous code
in JavaScript
so testing a secon code is quite complex
and is um it's not as straightforward as
testing normal functions that we've been
talking about and writing this whole
course so I'm going to show you how
we're going to be able to test a
synchronous code and it's actually quite
vital and important that we know how to
test a synchronous code because a
synchronous code is used the law in
JavaScript and it's very important so
let me just show you how just makes this
straightforward but before we do that
let me just quickly explain the concept
of a synchronous code so a synchronous
code in JavaScript allows for executing
some operations in the background and
not blocking the main execution thread
so this is crucial in JavaScript
especially in web environments because
it keeps the user interface responsive
while handling tasks like networks
request file operations or timers so
there are different ways that we're
going to different free method in
testing a code ingest which are
callbacks promises and async/await so
I'm going to first start with telling
you or showing you how to test callbacks
so the first thing that we're going to
do is to actually create a basic
callback function in here and let's get
started so right here in sjs I'm just
going to get rid of all of this and then
what I'm going to do is to just write a
very basic function so this function is
just going to as I said be a call back
function and then I'm going going to
show you what we're going to do to test
it I'm just going to say
function let's call it fetch
data and the call
back going to open and close that
function and let's set time out I'm
going to explain everything that this
code does in a
bit
so
then we're just going to open
up that and now we're going to call
back like a result so for this result
let's just say something like peanut
buttter let me colon and down here going
to set it to like let's say
1,000 and now we can just add our
semicolon right here now let me explain
what this code does real quick so this
is uh basic basic as I said a basic
function and the name of the function is
fetch data so what all of this does is
that it kind of simulates a delayed
operation so like an API call using set
timeout and then it calls a call back
with a result so once the API call has
been done or whatever operation we are
doing has been done then it calls a call
back with your result in this case the
result is pin Not Butter so that's what
this basic code does and I'm just going
to show you how to test that this code
Works using just right here now before
we go straight into testing this the
first thing we need to do is to make
sure that we're actually exporting this
PCH data function so that it can be
available in here in the test file so to
do this we're just going to say
module
export equals to fetch data so now we
are exporting fetch data and when we
require it here this is going to allow
us to just use that particular function
let's get rid of all of this and now
let's just write a basic test file basic
test code that we can use to test this
so let's say
test and let's say Okay nope this is not
what we want let's say the data
something like the
data is p
not and then we can
say done this done is very important
again I'm going to explain what this
code
does then going to open that now we're
going to write a
function we're going to say call back
going to take the
data and right now we're just going to
open this function and close it and
we're going to have a try accept can say
try open and close that I'm going to say
accept
data do
2b
peut data PE
but now we have to call it done so we
have to call this done so just knows
that we are done with what we're doing
and then down here say catch so this is
a try catch
syntax error to catch any error then
open and close that and say done
error that easy close this and then
right
here fetch data is the function that we
created right here fetch data and then
we're going to say call
back and then we're just going to add a
semicolon right here like
this now once again this is just a basic
code that is testing for this and and
I'm just going to explain what this does
so first of all we require this
particular fetch data right here from
here by just importing
this/ sum which is sum. GS and then
we're just giving it a description of
what this test is so we're saying that
once this test is run the data that is
being outputed should be pin data to
write whatever you want to write here
this is just the basic description so
yes and now what we're just doing is to
specify
and once we have this call back function
right here once we say we're trying and
remember the matches to be and accept so
accepting the data and we're saying it
should be P not butter and once we are
done with that we need to add the Dum
parameter which we did right here so we
need to add that D parameter because it
is used for callbacks that's what we did
here but now we also need to specify it
here it's important in calling that done
function to signal to just that the test
is complete so that's what we did right
here and that's also what we did right
here so now we're just going to go ahead
and actually test this particular or run
this particular test bring up my
terminal and what I'm just going to do
is to say mpm test going to hit enter
and now let's
see so it says one test failed and let's
see why the test is failed this is
because it says reference except is not
defined so let's go back can see why
this is
expect not accept now let's run that
again and now everything should be
working fine good as you can see it says
pass right here which is what we need
and it says the data is pin not data
which is good say one pass one total so
the amount of test we run was one and
out of that one one was passed this is
the time it used to run that test so
everything is working successfully now
in testing for callbacks now we are
going to be testing for promise based
functions so without wasting anytime
let's just get into it so let's close
down this terminal and we're going to
come back into some. JS we could change
this name to whatever we want but just
let's just leave it at su. JS and what
we're going to do now is to as I said
test for promise based functions the
first thing we need to do is to First
write U we're going to introduce a
function that returns a promise which
resolves after a delay so let's do that
right now so once again get rid of all
of this right here and then I'm just
going to say
function let's just name it fetch
promise and then we're going to open and
close that function and we're going to
say return
new promise so once again
um should have a basic knowledge of
JavaScript to be be able to follow along
with this tutorial cuz this is for
people that already know JavaScript and
want to learn how to test their
JavaScript code so we're going to say
resolve
reject and so this resolve and reject
just shows that it can be resolved and
also rejected and I'm going to show you
how we test for both if is resolved or
rejected now what we're going to do is
and close that we're just going to set
time out
this then we're going to
resolve let's just give you the same
thing we gave the last code we're going
to say p
Not
Butter say
th000 that all right here we're going to
have the semicolon also now this is the
basic code as I said this is just a
basic you know from promise a basic
function that returns a promise and as I
said it resolved after a delay so now
what we're just going to do is to make
sure that we export this out so that it
can be used in our test file so
module.
export equals to fetch promise semicolon
now we're going to come and test this
for us to test it once again the first
thing we need to do is get rid of all of
this and let's just say con going to say
f
promise equals to
require so don't allow we're just going
to say do slash
sum and now we're going to write the
test so we're going to say test this is
actually quite
straightforward
test the
data is peut
butter and right here we're going to
open and
close to the same here and now we're
going to return so we're going to say
ex fetch
promise so we're expecting a fetch
promise the resolves so if everything
works
fine 2B why ising the 2B matcher and we
expect it to be what it is right here P
bottom
so peanut
butter and we're going to add a
semicolon now let's save this and what
we're just going to do is let's make
sure we have our semicolon right here
this is basically what we need and let
me just pop this up and run mpm test now
let's see what happens it should be
passed as you can see it says pass this
is because everything works successfully
once if this is resolved right here it
gives us pin up butter that happens but
now let's just assume that fetch promise
can also reject because of course it can
resolve or reject now let's add a test
for if it rejects so say
test the
fetch fails with an
error something like that and then we'll
just going to do same
syntax and we're just going to say
return expect
fetch
promise going to say do
reject now we're going to say that to
throw remember when we talked about the
to throw matcher for if there is an
error now we're using that right here
and then we're just going to say
error right
here so right here is the way we can
write test for if the data so let's just
spell this
correctly the data is successfully
resolved or if the data is rejected so
this is the basic way we can just you
know as I said write test for for
promises for functions that uses
promises so it helps handling in
handling resolved and rejected promises
respectively now I'm going to show you
how to test with async await now we
don't even need to write any new
function right here we already have an
asynchronous function right here so we
don't really need to write any new
function I'm just going to show you how
to use a sing await to test this promise
function that we have right here so what
I'm just going to do is to come back in
here clear all of this I'm going to
leave this out so we don't need to
rewrite that and I'm just going to write
every the code out and then I'm going to
explain it to you in detail because this
is very crucial for you to understand so
the first thing I'm just going to do is
to write a new test just as we've been
doing we're just going to say not this
test say the data
peanut
butter and now we're going to say a
sync so a sync just basically signifies
make sure we're writing that well it
basically signifies that this is an
asynchronous function that's what async
does and now we're just going to open
that up and we're going to say
con data equals to await so AWA is is
using tandem is using constru con is
used alongside as sync So when you say a
sync you should write await right here
this just means that we are waiting for
the promise to resolve before making any
assertions so what we're just going to
do is to say
fetch
promise and
expect data and then we're going to use
the
2B
matcher
peanut
butter right here and then we do this so
this is just what we need to basically
test this out and what I'm going to do
is to explain as I said in detail what
this does so first I'm going to talk
about this async right here so as I said
it signifies once we have this async
function ASN keyword before the actual
function it signifies that this function
is going to be asynchronous so it's like
signal to JavaScript that the function
can pause and resume at some point and
especially to wait for as syn fonus
operations to complete that's what that
does and in testing this is very useful
for handling promises returned by the
code that you're testing so as you can
see we use that to handle this fetch
promise function now let's talk about
this await now this await is a keyword
that that is used alongside a sync so
when you use await before a function or
a promise what you are just saying is
that you're telling JavaScript to wait
till that promise settles and returns
its result now what we need to do is
to understand why what this await does
so is used as I said to pause the test
until the asynchronous function resultes
so when we say this await is going to
pause the test the test is not going to
go on until we get a result or this
promised function is being resolved so
that is what that helps us to do and
this I think a way it basically just
leads to more readable and cleaner test
code and that is why we use this most of
the time and I'm just going to run this
and show you that it works so I'm just
going to say mpm
test and right here you should see it
says fast but that works successfully
and that is how to use a sync await in
testing now let's talk about mock
functions and spice in testing so in
unit testing I isolating the component
being tested is very crucial and this is
where mocking and spying comes in so
mocks are fake implementations of real
functions and spies are tools that are
used to track the behaviors of those
functions so they track behaviors such
as whether the function has been called
or how many times it has been called or
with what arguments the function was
called
with now as I said mocking is used to
isolate the unit of code being tested so
it basically allows you to replace a
complex or slow or unavailable
dependency with simpler
versions and this isolation prevents
tests from being affected by external
factors and makes them more reliable and
faster to execute so let me give you an
example of why and when we can use this
so I'm going to give you an example of
like a database call so pain this
scenario imagine you have a function
that calls a database now testing this
function could be problematic because it
involves Network calls database setup
and stuff like that but by mocking the
database call we can simulate Its
Behavior and focus solely on testing the
functions logic now this is why testing
using mocking and spice is very
important now let's create and Implement
mock functions using just so the first
thing I'm going to show you how to do is
to use just. FN so just. FN is a way of
creating a mock function and it can be
implemented to return a specific value
of perform a specific action let me just
show you what I'm talking about so right
here in sum. test.js I'm going to remove
all of this and I'm just going to write
const let me just say something like
Mark call
back equals to just FN now we're
creating a mock function by saying just
FN and let's just say x equal
42 plus X so as you can see this is a
basic function and let's say I call this
by saying mock call back and I give it
zero now you if you understand
JavaScript you know that this is just
going to say 0 is equal to X so that
means 42 + 0 is = to X so the new value
of x will be 42 if I do the same and say
call back
one now this is just going to be 42 + 1
which is 43 now this is just a basic way
that we just created a mock function but
now I'm going to show you how to test
for a mock function by using just so
just going to get rid of all of this
real quick and I'm actually going to
write a real test now I'm going to say
let's remove that and let's give it a
description and the description will be
something like
mock
implementation so this is just like a
mock implementation let's say of a basic
function and now that
function just write this out that
function open and close and now we're
just going to create that same 42 plus X
that we created initially and I'm just
going to say const so as you can see
right here we're not actually doing
anything with the sum. JS because we
don't really need to do anything here
I'm just showing you how to implement a
mock function right here so we're just
going to say mock equals to just now
we're going to use just
FN and now we're going to say
x is
42 +
x as I said this is a very basic
function we're just going to do is going
to return 42 plus whatever value that we
give it is basically what we want so now
the next thing that we just need to do
is to
say
expect more Mark and we call one we
expect it to
be do to
be 43 so what this is just saying is
that if we call this mock right here and
give it a value of one or argument of
one the what should be returned the
value that we should get should be 43
and that is because once we give it one
it adds that one to 42 and it should be
43 so let's make sure this is 43
give the semicolon and for now let's
just save this and I'm just going to
pull this up and right here what we just
need to do is to say mpm
test now when we say mpm test just as
you can see it says one Past One total
right now this is just a very basic way
of using mock functions but we're going
to do one more thing I'm going to
introduce to you to have been C with so
is it's kind of like another match up we
haven't talked about this match up
before I'm going to show you what this
does right here so it's going to let's
just say right here I'm going to say
expect
Mark do to I've been called
with the H one
now let's also add this semicolon here
now this statement what it just does is
that it checks that the mock function
was called with the correct argument so
if this assertion failed then just to
provide an error message indicating what
went wrong so what we're just doing is
to make sure that we call this with one
because we did call it with one right
here we said mock one so this is just
saying we're checking that mock should
have been C with one we're just going to
do the same thing that we did run mpm
test and everything should also work
successfully nothing went wrong so this
is just a very basic way of using mock
function for testing right here in just
it's very easy it's very straightforward
now I'm going to show you how to use
just do spy on ingest so we're going to
use it to spy as I explained earlier in
this tutorial now what we're just going
to do is right here in some. test.js I'm
just going to go straight to writing
this test I'm going to say
test not
this going to say spying on a method of
an
object we're going to create that right
now and we're just going to say equals
this and we're going to create this and
we're going to say const video equals to
I'm going to open that up and say
play now we're going to open this play
function up too just say return
true right here and now we're just going
to comma and right here we're going to
add our
semicolon now we're going to add just
the spy on and why we're adding just the
spy on is basically like tracking this
particular video right here so we want
to track and see if this play has been
called in this video so what we're just
going to do right here is to say con
spy was just do spy
on we say video and we're going to spy
on
play write that and we're going to say
video do
play open and close and add the
semicolon and now we're going to say
expect spy
do two have been
called and what we're just going to say
spy. mock
restore now this is just a basic test
that we writing to track so let's get
rid of this we're writing to track and
make sure that this and track if this
play has been displ function has been
called right here and that's what we're
just doing is we're saying cons spy
we're saying just dop so this just dop
is just a method to track CS to video.
play so we're tracking when this video.
play has been called and just the spy on
this spy on right here it does not
replace the functions implementation
unlike just. FN that we talked about
earlier so this allows us to observe the
functions real Behavior now what we're
just going to do is to just go ahead and
run this and
just going to save this and then going
to pop up the
terminal all right you are just going to
say mpm
test just going to hit
enter so let's go back to terminal and
hit
enter as you can see it says one passed
so that means it has been done
successfully so as you can see
everything works and let me just quickly
explain this cuz we didn't talk about
this so so expect spy. to have been
called with so this line will check if
the play method was called so this
basically validates the spies
functionality that we created so that's
what these two have been called with
does and the last thing we're going to
talk about is this spy mock restore
function so this spy Mo restore function
in just is used to restore the original
implementation of that function so the
function that has been spied on using
just do spy on this that is what is
being used to restore the original
implementation of that function now when
we create a spy on a function just
basically replaces the Spy function with
a mock function now this allows you to
like track calls argument and return
values of that function but in some
cases you might want to revert the
function back to its original
implementation that is why we use spym
restore and that is what we did right
here so that is the end of this tutorial
and I hope you understood everything we
did in this tutorial if you did please
don't forget to click on the like button
and subscribe and I'll see you in the
next one